l'eau propose maintenant de terminer
cette édition sur un triomphe celui de
deux français il ne s'agit pas de sport
cela se passait hier soir à bayreuth
pendant une heure et demie les
fanatiques de wagner ont ovationné hier
soir pierre boulez et patrice chéreau 90
minutes d'applaudissements 107 rappel
c'était la dernière représentation de la
tétralogie et pour la première fois une
caméra celle d'antenne 2 pénétrait à
bayreuth georges bigot vient d'ailleurs
de rencontrer patrice chéreau 85 minutes
d'applaudissements 101 rappelle alors
dans quel état vous êtes vous senti hier
comment avez vous appréhendé ce triomphe
oui c'est très surfait
j'aurais pas avoir l'air dégoûté non
plus ça fait toujours plaisir évidemment
mais ce qui me semble important c'est
que c'est qu'on soit quand même
finalement arrivés au bout de ce qu'on
voulait avec avec ce spectacle c'est à
dire que en cinq ans n'a réussi à faire
d'abord à convaincre le public de
bayreuth ensuite à le changer même en
partie et que je suis arrivé qu'on soit
arrivé pierre boulez et moi faire que le
spectacle existe qui existe comme on le
voulait vous avez eu des difficultés ça
veut dire que bayrou c'est quelque chose
de très particulier et ce pont peut
l'expliquer rapidement oui bayrou c'est
quelque chose de particulier parce que
il y a depuis très longtemps toujours
une sorte de culte de wagner comme ça
qui est inculte exagéré d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon les n 10 qui ont que qui
ont provoqué cette mise en scène les
sifflets et tout ça était exagérée de
même une certaine façon le le succès
actuel est aussi exagéré en partie je
veux dire que ce qui est intéressant
d'en bas est vrai c'est que d'un endroit
qui était entre guillemets un temple
dans
moi qui étais qui était voué un peu au
culte de wagner et depuis là depuis
l'après guerre
finalement les héritiers de wagner on en
ont fait un théâtre en parfait ordre de
marche à laquelle on peut expérimenter
des choses
enfin selon leurs propres termes un
atelier c'est d'abord un très très beau
tu es en train dans un bâtiment
magnifique avec une acoustique parfaite
et cet interne dans laquelle on peut
vraiment travailler se concentrer sur un
spectacle et faire que ce spectacle
aille jusqu'au bout de l'idée qu'on
essaye de lui donner de lui insuffler un
peu de gens assistent au spectacle de
byron et pour cause les places sont
prises allant à l'avance alors une
wagner ça a pourtant une actualité qui
intéresse tout le monde
oui je plus daguenet ça une actualité je
crois je dis au bac mais ce ne sont pas
des opéras comme les autres c'est-à-dire
qu'il ya qui est né ce sont 7 unis ce
sont des histoires formidables qui sert
à caen qui sont racontées ce sont des
histoires qui parlent de légende qui
parle de l'histoire du 19e siècle et ce
sont des choses qui nous parle à nouveau
profondément c'est plus que de la
musique c'est plus que de l'opéra c'est
plus que du terme
c'est un mélange à mon avis
particulièrement réussie
il est
mais
et
oui